si ces deux agents municipaux ont décidé
de faire appel
c'est qu'ils se disent innocents malgré
les accusations de leur ex collègue
principal mis en cause dans cette
affaire et déjà condamné alors bien sûr
il y à des versements sur leur compte en
banque par liasses de billets ou sacs
entiers de pièces l'avocat général les a
qualifiées d' éminemment suspect mais
les deux hommes ont une explication
revente d'objets de collection pour l'un
ou gares de paris sportifs pour l'autre
sans pouvoir apporter un quelconque
justificatifs
comme l'a précisé dans le dossier la
française des jeux quand vous pariez
vous revenez au point d'accueil
française des jeux vous donnez votre
ticket on vous donne des billets vous
n'avez pas le moindre justificatif
peut-être qu'il ya quelque chose à ce
niveau là à voir mais en l'occurrence ce
qu'il a fait est tout à fait légal au vu
de l'instruction ce détournement
d'horodateurs semblait à l'époque d'une
facilité déconcertante
il suffisait pour un agent receveur
indélicat de vider la caisse de la
machine garder pour soi la recette sans
donner le ticket récapitulatif du
montant collecté est délivrée par
l'horodateur
quelques temps plus tard le voleur
n'avait plus qu'à remettre ceux reçus
dans les archives de compte personne ne
pointez vous ne contrôlez à 30 ans à
l'audience la commune n'est même pas
capable de nous dire le montant précis
des sommes qui auraient été détournés
pourquoi est ce qu'on vient nous dire
que d'abord les ornements son auteur de
140000 euros puis au bout de trois mois
il serait à 260 milles euros
et finalement on a deux personnes qui
sont poursuivis pour un montant total de
8000 euros
où est passé cet argent c'est
surréaliste
la municipalité n'a pas souhaité
commenter un contentieux en cours
l'avocat général a réclamé que la peine
de 12 mois de prison avec sursis énoncé
en première instance soit confirmée les
avocats de la défense ont plaidé la
relaxe pour l'heure deux clients
le jugement a été mis en délibéré au 27
octobre prochain